higher gas prices this summer won't
prevent families from getting behind the
wheel nearly two-thirds of people
planning vacations this summer will
drive to their destinations trends show
that smaller cities have a resurgence as
Americans like to stay close to home and
enjoy unique urban experiences
well Priceline is watching those trends
very closely founded in 1998 it's one of
the original online travel agencies one
and a half million people visit the site
every single day to look for deals on
flights hotels rental cars and cruises
CEO Brett Keller is here as his company
celebrates its 20th anniversary Wow it's
his first Network interview since he
became CEO back in 2016
good morning mr. Keller welcome to the
table thank you for having me so I have
heard from reliable sources that you've
been at the company 19 out of 20 years
true yes what was your first job there
my first job was in marketing I came in
to help run our email marketing and help
develop some of the product experiences
on the website so when you started did
you say one day I'm gonna run this place
in 20 years late 19 years later here you
are absolutely not and no idea I'd end
up where I was today but 20 but 20 years
you're still very relevant how is that
Priceline yeah well Priceline's had to
evolve this is a very competitive
industry Travel has you know it's a it's
a trillion-dollar worldwide industry and
price lines had to evolve as products
we've had to become more mobile friendly
you know with the launch of the iPhone
in 2008 it really changed how consumers
will travel how has that in the 19 years
you've been there
give us what it was like at the
beginning when people were probably like
what how do I huh and now where it
becomes second nature in the way people
travel sure you know back in 1998 when
the website first launched it would
literally take you 45 minutes to go
through the process of booking an
airline ticket back then we had we were
really a Travel disrupter with our name
your own price service and you would
come in you name your own price and it
would take you an hour to get your
answer just to see if you really got
your ticket you know today consumers can
pick up a phone fire up the Priceline
app and book a hotel within a matter of
seconds it's really significantly
changed and now you have peer-to-peer
rentals obviously Airbnb how do you
compete in this new environment where
you're sort of the dinosaur you know we
like to think that we have a lot of
history and experience in booking travel
travels are very complex
system and over the years we have
accumulated a really broad set of
inventory around hotels today we have
over a million and a half hotels on our
platform and you cannot only book hotels
on Priceline now you can book things
like condos apartments B&BS and other
really interesting properties and we
still deliver the type of savings we did
in 1998 and in travel that's the most
important deciding factor when it comes
to booking you know today Twitter is one
of the latest companies that's having
issues with passwords when people are
giving their information to you how do
you make sure that it's protected well
we do our very best to use the most
modern technology to protect our
consumers data and of course to be
careful about who has access to that to
that data to make sure that's protected
I mean that's one of the number one
things that we talk about all the way up
to our awards what are the top
destinations what are you seeing well
this year in particular we've seen an
interesting rise in some urban locations
specifically in Detroit and Cleveland in
Detroit yes those are very fast-growing
markets why do you think that is I think
they're going through a bit of a
renaissance they've got a lot of really
interesting and urban culture happening
there a lot of new restaurants breweries
night scenes and I know that Detroit was
named the most exciting city in America
just a couple of months ago by the New
York Times and people are certainly
demonstrating that by their travel
trends well people in Detroit will be
glad to hear that have you seen people
changing the way they go on vacation in
other words do they want to just go
somewhere sit down and just forget it
all or do they want to be active go see
these fascinating new things and all
these yeah yeah absolutely you know 20
years ago a typical trip is you fly out
on the same airline you fly back on the
same airline you stay for four or five
days at the same hotel people don't
travel that way anymore today people
want to fly to a destination maybe stay
with the friends for a couple of days
drive down the coast book a hotel at the
last minute and the mobile applications
have enabled people to do that and we're
developing at Priceline more flexible
packaging systems that allow you to
build those kinds of trips to really
facilitate that type of travel and say
another gem of a city in the country is
New Orleans and you're seeing a real big
increase in bookings 150% increase right
for Memorial Day weekend what's going on
and why haven't we both yet guys
New Orleans is a great market and in at
that time of year you know the weather's
nice there's so many great places to any
food is so yes and a lot of really nice
boutique hotels to stay in and how is
William Shatner helped the company
because whenever I think of Priceline
that I really do think about William
Shatner well you are no different than
the rest of America that's we run
surveys we ask what do you think of me
to think of Priceline travel deals and
William Shatner
he's been integral to the brand he was
with the company before it even launched
in 1998 he's been with us as a
spokesperson that entire time and really
is has been the face of priceless he
surpassed you even and you've been there
for 19 he's endless and he's offering
presents I hear coming up yeah this over
the next 20 days we're launching the
biggest Salem industry of Priceline to
commemorate our 20-year anniversary and
our hope is to save America's 50 million
dollars over the next 20 days America
say good news thank you